the town of grenier is just 30
kilometers south of paris
and it's already infamous in france as
being one of the country's
poorest areas and home to one of
europe's biggest
housing complexes now nearly half of the
residents who live
in that complex behind me live below the
poverty line
things were already bad before kovite 19
ravaged through this community now the
mayor
is sounding the alarm saying the
pandemic is causing
a social tsunami between
last march and december the number of
unpaid charges including for water and
heating has practically doubled
and if we can't pay for the water and
heating that means we also
can't pay for upkeep and emergency
repairs
with no money coming in local
authorities will
struggle to keep things afloat here
meaning
the problems in this town could
spiral we spoke to one resident who
didn't want to show her face on camera
but told us as people were getting
poorer
the basics that were needed for life
were even
further out of reach gurini is one of
the poorest towns in france
and has been known for a long time
because there are many types of poor
inhabitants
lots of immigrants that's causing a
crisis in the town
and during the covet pandemic it has
worsened many have lost their jobs
and many students have found themselves
without resources without help
without anything at all and she says the
problems here are
getting out of control
it's a social catastrophe because
poverty is growing people have
difficulties to make it to the end of
the month
there's also criminality that pushes
young people towards bad things
there are more and more problems here
there is
aid in grinny a number of associations
offer help to those who are struggling
food distribution as well as moral
support is
being doled out but more and more people
are finding themselves in need
people here feel isolated forgotten
it's been very very difficult for many
families because they haven't been able
to walk
because they've lost jobs but they had
temporary walk contracts i had problems
finding a job
it's a catastrophe i have been looking
everywhere
it's become worse with the pandemic in
every sense if i try to find a job i
won't be able to do it at my age
but it also affects our children they
have nothing to do here
they're struggling to find a job for
many
now the key issue is how to survive but
so to have to crawl out
from the poverty trap jobs have been
lost hope
has been lost too and without either
residents like
lima see no future here
i don't want my children to stay here in
france in greeny and particularly
and in france in general there are fewer
and fewer opportunities to find a job
yet they have education that elsewhere
could give them a stable future
what chance they have remains to be seen
charlotevinsky rt renee esson